you look like a Friday white dude dude I
don't know how the [__] you pulled that
off I swear to God I thought that was a
practical joke at first just like that's
an Indian you're in college or what
what's going on
you just graduated okay well you need to
start dressing like it at some point are
you in a fraternity not anymore I knew
he was in a fraternity guys I'm nice at
judging people in college you could get
[__] dressed like that in the real
world no chance dog you're scared by
looking at you like get a job bro come
on you came out like this on a Friday
night that's your girl she put your her
arm on your shoulder like um excuse me
just like a white person to start
claiming territory isn't it holy [__]
you can't stop him